hello everyone
uh thank you so much for joining us my
name is vijay sairam and i will be your
moderator for today's webcast
on maximizing microservices managing
complexity and extending value with
apogee
and istio a few housekeeping tips you
can find links to the references made
during this webcast on the resource
console of your screen
should you have any questions please
feel free to post them anytime in the qa
console
you don't have to wait till the end of
the session so please feel to post them
in
as soon as you have them also we will be
recording this webinar
and it will be emailed to all the
registrants of the webinar
in today's session we will talk about
the essentials for
maximizing your microservices strategy
we have planned for a very practitioner
heavy session
we have two demos that will demonstrate
how we are working to help you manage
complexity
and extend value of your microservices
with apogee and steel with that said i
would like to welcome
our speakers for today's session and
then
uh sridhar product manager and
um at google cloud and scott kanye a
software engineer at
google cloud london has over 14 years of
it experience in financial services
enterprise architect
architecture software development and
i.t consulting
and has played multiple roles of an
architect designer mentor and technical
specialist
he currently helps customers design
beautiful apis
through apigee edge and he's deeply
interested in the spaces of api security
and microservices scott daniel
is a prolific software developer with
over 25 years of hands-on expertise
in development architecture resource and
leadership
and is very passionate about
microservices again
with that said welcome to both speakers
and with i would like to now hand it
over
to nanda thank you so much vijay
appreciate the introduction
thank you all for uh taking time to
attend this webinar
so i'll give you a brief overview of
what you should expect from today's
session
we're going to talk about the concept of
service meshes what is a service mesh
why do you think
it's even there what is istio the value
proposition for sku
how does this fear solve the problem and
then we'll have a demo of
istio right after that we're going to
take a look at api management as it
relates to microservices
how does service management and api
management coexist
complement or are they the same thing
and lastly we're going to take a look at
how apigee integrates
with sdo and then we'll have a demo for
that as well
so um with without without further ado
let's go uh dig into this and see
uh you know what is mesh it's not a lot
of enterprises either considering
or have already started building new
services using a microservices
architecture
and we all know that microservices are
awesome so
why is that the case what was wrong with
the previous mechanism
well this would be a fairly good
generalization of a monolithic
architecture
we've got some users the front-end
business logic is in a monolithic
application that connects to
one or more databases now this
architecture did have some advantages
you know if you did have a very complex
application this worked just fine
it was easy to from a production point
of view easy to troubleshoot
if you had latency issues you know
exactly
where to look is that one monolithic
application
um and if you had to deploy something
you just deployed that app
and and you're done there are some
disadvantages
to it as well the severely impeded
uh agility especially as that
application became
more complex the front-end team may be
making some changes
the second team may be making changes
every change required you to test that
entire monolithic application and this
was definitely a problem
and increase the ownership cost for that
application
and so we know that you know micro
services solve that problem
so micro services started decomposing
this monolithic application
started to decompose this monolithic
application
into independent units functional units
so that development teams could operate
on those
functional services independent of each
other
so in this example that monolithic
application
was split into an invoicing microservice
a front-end microservice
a nosql db cluster and so on and so if i
were making changes to the invoicing
application i didn't have to involve the
front-ending team i could make those
changes
and iterate much faster without
involving other teams
there are also some interesting
byproducts from this architecture
not just related to agility the first is
that
we could use the right programming
language for our microservices
the front-end team could use uh
javascript node.js
the invoicing team could use
springboot.net or something else
and they really didn't have um they need
to have much in common
the second thing is that as one
microservice
called another microservice i.e when
they
transferred responsibility from one
microservice to the other
they did it over the network
a very common pattern would be that the
invoicing microservice exposed its
interface
as an api over http and the front-end
application didn't have to know
how it was implemented or who it was
implemented or anything
as long as that contract was maintained
the the front-end application
could involve it can invoke the
invoicing application
so this definitely promoted agility you
could introduce
changes much quicker and and uh
you know this will definitely a huge
benefit from the microservices
architecture
because people started adopting more of
these microservices
you know they started making them more
fine-grained and
before you know your architecture ends
up looking like this
because the more fine-grained you make
it the more quickly you can iterate on
one of those
uh individual micro services now this
on the face of it can look pretty
daunting
so what you're seeing here is a network
of
uh micro services that make up one or
more monolithic applications
this network of micro services is what
we call
the service crash and as you can tell
as you build more and more microservices
this network can become massive
and complex and this complexity becomes
very difficult to manage and
understand if you put yourself in the
shoes of a production operator
managing this sort of a microservices
architecture and you
had a performance problem to identify
it's going to be pretty difficult to
identify
which micro service actually was causing
the performance issue
because of so many microservices running
all at the same time
another issue is with introducing
agility while keeping your risk low if
the invoicing team is quickly iterating
making and making changes
what if it breaks what if they pushed a
inaccurate change
that broke a contract and now it causes
a cascading effect
of breaking other microservices and
that's the third issue
what about governments you have many
teams developing microservices using
programming and platform choices that
they want to make that's best suited for
their
microservice but then how do you how
does a security admin
guarantee that they're all adopting best
practices of security
how do you know that they're all
adopting the right standards for logging
tracing and everything else
so there is a governance issue now so we
identified
three interesting things right how do
you observe
right the second is how do you do
operational agility without introducing
more risk and third how do you do a
uniform security from this
so it's easy for one to think that micro
services are in fact terrible
you know monolithic problems didn't have
this problem well
obviously that's not the right answer um
microservices are
perfectly fine yes these three are an
issue
and this is exactly why this deal exists
istio
is an open services platform to manage
your service
interactions on containers and vm based
workloads
that second part is super important it's
also for vm-based workloads
and i mentioned service interactions
that's exactly what a service mesh is
right managing the interactions of your
network of your micro services
is what steer does what do i mean by
manage them and that's what we'll dig
deeper into
as we get into what steer does
so istio solves the three problems i
brought up earlier
when you're dealing with microservices
gives you
observability right second it
you can do you can have operational
agility i.e
the ability to introduce changes quickly
into your system without introducing
additional risks
and third you can introduce policies for
security without
having to depend on individual teams to
adopt those policies and you can as a as
a
enterprise standard apply broad security
rules and not expect individual teams
to apply them on every microservice so
this is a quick
value proposition for what istio does
now what we are going to look at
is to see how istio does it
the basic architecture construct for
istio
looks like this at this point i'll
introduce the concept of a sidecar
now you'll see here i've got two
services a and b and both have a proxy
associated with it
that proxy is what we refer to as a site
car
a quick definition here of what a site
card is
a site car is a process that assists
a parent process where the parent
process can
transfer responsibility to the sidecar
so in this case service a is a
microservice i've written
and instead of the microservice or the
microservice developer
implementing every bit of the
instead of the microservices developer
implementing every bit
of the architecture the microservice
developer is offloading
certain responsibilities to the proxy
besides our proxy now you must assume
that as if the site start proxy is part
of your application
if the cycle proxy is on your micro
services down it really is
a one-to-one mapping and most of the
times they share a kernel
um if you're putting it on vms and if
you're not on vms they're in the same
pod if it's kubernetes
so for all practical purposes that cycle
proxy is part of your application
that microservices team must treat that
cycle property as if it were part of
that
microservice it is only then can you
rely on the flightcard proxy
to do certain or take up certain
responsibilities instead of the
individual microservices
doing it so what responsibilities can i
delegate to this website
so first off there are two things that a
microsoft service does very often
then it invokes other microservices or
it gets invoked by other microservices
so these are easily broken down into two
aspects
ingress or an egress so they take all
the other services
or other services called services
what happens with this gear is that the
siter proxy
intercepts all ingress or outbound
or and all ingress or all inbound
traffic to the microservice
so the microservice itself is never
directly accessible
without going through the cycle proxy
and this is a fundamental point
when you have the cyclar proxy
associated with
every one of your microservices you
quickly realize
that all your network traffic is
happening
between two cycles never happens between
the applications themselves
and this is a fundamental point to
understand
as as to how istio operates and how it
is able to achieve the value
propositions we talked about
i.e observability agility and security
so now that we have established that all
inbound and outbound services go through
the sitestar
will now start talking about what is it
we do and how we do it
right so assisting the fighter are three
components
i'm going to briefly touch upon them now
but we are
soon going to have a slide that explains
individually what these components do
the first is pilot while it helps with
service discovery i have a
write about it and we'll talk about it
then and the second
is a policy decision point which is
mixer it
enforces policies in the service mesh
and unfortunately you can't see the
slide here but the last one is citadel
citadel will help with security
citadel is a ca certificate authority so
you can achieve
mutual tls between uh your services
let's start with security first right so
we've established a basic premise that
there is a sidecar in front of all your
micro services
and that sidecar has some delegated
responsibilities
let's start with security how does
security happen
with this deal the three
important security points that estio
provides
the first is enabling mutual tls that is
authentication
and encryption between your services and
this is a very fundamental point
individual applications no longer have
to implement tls
my microservice in service a or my micro
service service b
need to have absolutely no knowledge of
how to do tls
right that responsibility of negotiating
tls
um is offloaded to convoy or the cycle
proxy but doing this i have now
implemented a standard way of achieving
pls
regardless of whether it's a database
regardless whether
it's a document application or a java
application there is one way to do
mtls and that's still using the sidebar
the second is to authorize access based
on service identity
another crucial and critical point and i
have a slide about it
but i'll briefly touch upon it here the
site
or in istio every microservice has a
service identity
and we'll come to that in a second and
then i can apply
authorization rules on those services
so for example i can say that only
service a can access service b
and no other service that is achievable
because
we identify the workload or the service
with an identity a service identity
and that can be used to apply
authorization
lastly you can also apply some very
fine-grained
rpc controls for example i
want to allow service a to access
service b but it can only
access the get operations and nothing
else or
only the post operations and nothing
else and so
it can also be a very fine-grained
organization
so let's take a quick look at what are
these
and what these options mean in in detail
so of course mutual tls is a very
standard practice for securing
communication between two services
mutual tls we all use it for
encryption of messages in transit but
there is
some more we can do with this what istio
provides
is this ability called a strong
authentication and i touched upon it
briefly
before istio provides the ability to
create a service identity
now how do we do this so
there is a standard called spiffy spi
ffe for those of you who are interested
and citadel is a certificate authority
that is responsible for signing
certificates
in the standard so when service pay is
brought up service a gets a unique
service identity
no other service can pretend to be
service a i can uniquely identify
service a and this is
extremely useful to authenticate that
my service is in fact coming from
service a and not someone else
so it's easy for me to have a rule in
service b to say
i will only accept communication from
service a
the the in order for me to do that i
must have
a strong way of achieving the identity
that
that is service a and this is done
through spiffy based certificates
a second very critical point is how
these certificates
are automatically rotated so every 30
minutes in sto a new key insert pair is
generated
and this new end key cell is issued to
service a and these certificates keep
rotating
in my past life i remember we struggled
a lot when it came to certificate
upgrade with these giant monolithic
applications
with the java key stores and everything
we took
there was at times downtime too for us
to upgrade these certificates
that could be a thing of the past when
you use steel because certificates are
rotated
all the time every 30 minutes and
automatically
the second component i want to introduce
here is mixer
mixer is that extensibility point that
allows you to make policy decisions in a
steer
a mixer integrates with apigee mixer
integrates with stackdriver mixer
integrates with prometheus and graphana
and all these other systems so mixer has
two
main roles the first is that it collects
telemetry information
from the istio architecture we talked
about how there's a sidestar in front of
every application
this presents us to some very
interesting options in addition to mtls
these cyclops can emit events every time
there's an ingress or immediate
those events can be captured by
centralized systems
to produce tracing information
monitoring information
so you get observability without
changing any of your applications
regardless of the code they're written
in
mixer is that centralized case where
these
telemetry events are collected
but mixer also has another role to play
mixer is a policy decision point
this is where you can hold your
authorization rules to say
i want only solitary to access b or i
want service a to only have
read access to b and so on these are
authorization
rules or policy decision rules that i
can encode into mixers
and those decisions are then enforced by
the site class
the mixer provides that extensibility to
add
those custom rules into sql
the last and final component here is
pilot
pilot is responsible for configuring
a control thing so pilot has two jobs
one is is providing service discovery
information when you have a new service
that is registered pilot knows about it
and lets the psychologist know about it
and second if you're doing things like
canadian releases
a b testing all of these rules are coded
into pilot and pilot pushes that
information
to service a so in this case if i had
there is a new version of service b
and i want to send 20 of my traffic to
this new service
then here is a example of a yaml file
of how i could do it 80 percent of my
traffic still goes to the existing
service
20 goes to my new service and this is a
very critical point in maintaining
operational agility right we talked
about
two things we talked about observability
we talked about security
and this is the third one this is how we
introduce
operational agility this allows
development teams to iterate very fast
because when you do introduce a new
version
you don't have to use 10 100 of your
traffic to this new version
you could start with five percent test
if there are errors and if there are
errors
easily switch back to the previous
version and then no errors continue to
increase traffic
to this newer version what does istio do
in summary the value proposition for
istio is that
managing microservices can be
complicated it
presents a challenge to production
operators of how to get
observability how to introduce
operational agility without
increasing risk and third how to do
policy driven security so you're not
depending on individual teams to do it
and he still addresses these
concerns on behalf of the application of
the microservices provider
by baking these features into the basic
infrastructure
we still can do the routing if you can
do the security
and it still can introduce the
observability for what is happening
in your infrastructure so at this point
what we're going to do
is i'm going to get my colleague scott
scott daniel is going to do a quick demo
of his video and he's going to show you
how it still works thank you nandan
what i've put together here is it's a
storefront
so that i'm i'm going to operate now
at at this point as the the operator of
of my store here and
i'm pretty uh satisfied with what i've
got i can
go in and you know buy typewriter
edit my card view the card i've got all
of the
the standard capabilities that you would
expect in the storefront
now this whole thing has been created
as a series of microservices
now all of this is actually deployed in
a kubernetes environment
and each of these services
is developed in different style
different language
we have everything from python to java
to go
represented here as well as
you know database information and
accessing external
services as well so
the the issue here then of course
uh as nandon talked about is you know
how do we how do we manage all of this
well the first thing i want to show you
is a very simple thing
but a very powerful thing and that is
being able to
route information
[Music]
as uh as like a canary
type implementation and so
nandin showed you uh a version of the
yaml uh this is a slightly different
version
and you notice my uh my shop
is a lot of gray
that's my color but i've heard now that
blue is is the hip color
and so what i've done is i've rolled out
or i've deployed a version
of my app that takes into
account the fact that i've heard that
people like blue
so what you see here is i've changed the
virtual service
and i've set up a destination so subsets
of 80 of the requests go to gray
and 20 go to blue
so once i that
we're configured now now whenever we go
through here you'll see every once in a
while
we'll get a blue page
but my header is going to be
either gray or blue depending on how we
hit it
so that's cool that means i can test
that uh that small change in the a b way
or in a canary type rollout
and i can easily get back from it
because it turns out
that my customers actually really
preferred the gray
and i can just roll that back with
another quick change
where i set 100 of my traffic
back to gray and i will never see that
blue abomination again
so that's a quick example of you know
how
how you actually use the the routing
capabilities
another thing that i want to show you
real quick though is some of the
monitoring
if we jump in uh we have full telemetry
information and tracing
information and this is the jaeger
ui and it shows you the requests that
have been coming
through and i can actually drill down
into one of these
and see exactly where all the time
is being spent like what's being called
and how long it's taking so if i need to
get information and about the actual
operation of of what's going on i can
very easily
figure out where i need to make
optimizations or i need to make changes
to fix things the other thing i want to
show you is
is grafana and if you look
you can get a very detailed view of the
information about the system
of the memory cpu you know all the
information about that
i can also show you
a service dashboard on end service
and it shows you request volume success
rate things like that
so we have we have very detailed
information about what's going on in the
system
and all this is just absolutely built
into istio
and available at all times and can be
extended as well uh various plugins
so i'm going to hand this back to
non-demand
so what we have seen now is how to use
istio to do basic service management
right what you've seen with service
management needs
are the basic ability to do mpls so you
can encrypt and authenticate your
traffic
i think you want to have this
operational agility so you can do a b
testing you can do canadian releases
all of that and third you want to do
policy enforcement
they apply to all services
right and this is back to that so how
does
how does service management really tie
in with api management
so first let us establish what is api
management
and then let's talk about how service
management compares
with api management api management is
the ability
to provide an api catalog for discovery
if you go back to this architecture here
this is the
application that scott wrote it's got a
currency service that's got a checkout
service
very frequently in enterprises the team
that builds the currency service is
different from the team that build the
checkout service now that team
that builds the currency service will
very frequently want to have
exposed that service in some sort of a
catalog that's available in the
enterprise
and the team that built the checkout
service will refer to the currency
services api specification
potentially request access to it and if
access should be granted
by the team that build the currency
service they will grant that access and
then you go ahead and build it
so while at the service to service
communication path one of this was
visible
at the development stages when these
services were in fact being shared
between teams api management was
definitely needed
so let's reiterate that if i am just
building certain services that is only
ever going to be consumed
from within my team then by all means
something like a javadoc or a readme
file is good enough to share information
about how to consume that other service
but the minute you want your service to
be available
outside your team into a consumable form
then you want to have a catalogue to
publish it the moment you have a catalog
where people can consume your services
you want to have the ability to control
who has access and how they have access
to it
and so on the next step is
from a the ability to view usage
reporting
you saw scott show us the distributed
trade which said you know this is how
much latency is spent in
every single microservice and so on but
neither nor the jaeger ui showed scott
who his top biggest five applications
are
because istio does not have the view of
an application it has viewer services
and many services form an application
like for example your call center
application isn't one big
application but it is a bunch of
microservices but if you want that view
of what does it
look like from an application level
which is a logical grouping of
microservices
you want to have some analytics being
reported
if you want to productize your
data and expose it to others for
monetization purposes
very likely you're not going to
productize individual microservices but
you're going to productize
a logical grouping of these
microservices and make it available as
a single api and lastly of course you
want to have the ability to do
documentation try your apis and so on
then there is the aspect in an api
gateway
within an api gateway i want the ability
to do transformations and mediations i
want the ability to do
throttling encoders i want thread
protection for my json and xml payloads
and i want some caching optimization
techniques to be available
these are certain cross-cutting concerns
that you want in a gateway so that again
individual micro service developers
don't have to do it
so keeping these in mind let's now
compare api management
and service management all
apis are services but not all services
are apis your caching service
is a service but it's not an api your
website is a service
but it's not an api but the inviting
service
is also an api because i could invoke it
as an api
so we think that hto and service
management is needed for all services
anything with at least a tcp port can be
managed by sdo
that could mean your database that could
mean your nosql database whatever that
may be
and when some of those services need to
be exposed for consumption outside of
your team
and it becomes an api and you need api
management
for it and that's how we try to look at
api management and service management
they are really complementary functions
even if you drill down into the features
offered by both of them you'll notice
that
although the feature section looks
similar they offer different
perspectives
api management of course works on http
based
apis but service management can apply to
a tcp based
service and that's perfectly fine when
it comes to authorization and
authentication
service management relies on mutual tls
and the
identity in the spp certificate for
identity
whereas api management can rely on api
keys and or tokens
and not necessarily at the mtls level
when you look at monitoring it's really
monitoring from a production
production operations team point of view
it's a production
ops person who wants to know the
distributed trace to find
bottlenecks apigee's monitoring is more
from
a api's provider point of view where
you're going to try and
take it as who which application that's
consuming me is causing the most errors
who are my top 10 developers and you see
how this monitoring almost leads into
analytics rate limiting is also very
different
a rate limiting for service management
is more to do with i want to protect my
back end
but the rate limiting from an api
management point of view is from a
consumer point of view to say
i don't want these consumers to exceed
their quota
i want to create a gold tier i want to
create a platinum tier i want to create
a
bronze tier and so on these are all
consumer specific
they are not backend specific
lastly monetization is and portals are
abilities that come with
api management you don't really monetize
services
you monetize apis so i hope you're
drawing this distinction of how
service management and api management
are complementary features
service management is needed for all
your services and when those some of
those services become apis
you use api management
so how do we how do we apigee integrate
with spo
now assuming that you have already got
hto to do services
management then how do we layer on top
of this to also do
api management what you're seeing here
is the architecture that we have
for services management it includes the
sidecar it includes mixer and pilot
and i have on purpose not introduced
citadel here
it's not relevant to this current
conversation but it could have been here
so about service management here in my
previous slide
we talked about how mixer is that
extensibility point
and as you would have guessed it
naturally we would extend mixer
to add api management capabilities
in addition to that we introduced two
important concepts
the concept of an api portal and the
concept of an api
dashboard to view the metrics and mixer
becomes a policy decision point to do
api key or forward verification it's the
point where you do quota enforcement
and it's also the place where you
collect analytics to send it off
to the dashboard
the next point is how does apogee do it
well
naturally we integrate the mixer
component of sdo
to talk to apogee edge or the control
plane in
apigee edge so that the hdm mixer
is apigee aware and this is a very
critical point
you have now with the integration of
mixer to apigee edge you have now made
istio apigee api management aware
mixer is now able to enforce the rules
that you define in apigee
so apigee becomes a place where you
author entitlements api becomes a place
where you publish
your services for your portal and those
rules
are pulled down by mixer and then
enforced
in the service mesh so let's take this
with an actual example
we had the the retail site fazio that
subscribed
and now his car has got a new
requirement his new requirement is
the shipping service needs to be exposed
externally
and that's the requirement he had so far
the shipping service
was only used by the checkout service
and that was never exposed outside
and it was all done through the
front-end application
but now his requirement is to actually
expose the shipping service
as an api so start tell us how you do
this
okay thanks nandan so what we're going
to do first off
is expose our new tracking api we have a
service
and we already have a gateway that's
exposing
the application itself but what we need
down here is to expose the tracking and
route it to our
shipping our shipping microservice
and allow access through that
so once we apply this then we will have
access that's configured
we will have access into this api
as you can see here
the next step that we're going to look
at is wiring up
apogee so
we need to be able to apply apogee
analytics
to our istio routing and or to our istio
application and we also want to apply
authorization right now
i'm going to show you a little bit of
how that wiring happens
the apogee analytics as you can see here
this this little uh crd basically tells
istio mixer which attributes an istio to
send
to apogee and you can see we have
request times and destination hosts and
things like that so this is the
analytics part
and we also have a template for
authorization that tells
mixer which parts of the authorization
when it does authorization which
attributes from mixer need to go to
apogee so that we can do that as well
and here you'll see ap things like api
key and you'll see
claims from oauth and things like that
so we in both cases we're able to report
on
not just the request itself but who's
making the request
the next thing that we'll do is apply a
rule
now this is what actually tells mixer
that
we want to send in this case we're going
to send all inbound requests
to the apigee adapter and thus to apogee
and this is for analytics so we'll take
everything that there is
configure that rule and now we can look
at the analytics reporting
now when you get into apogee analytics
it gives you all kinds of great
information
this for example shows uh by device type
but you can also you can drill in on
this one
to various uh services
so we can look at you know the product
catalog service and how it's
uh you know how it's been hit
we can look at error code analysis and
actually see
if we're getting errors and we're not
getting many
we can look at developer engagement
is interesting once we have a set of
developers and we'll talk about that in
just a moment
and then um actually api proxy
performance as well
so you can see all the developers and
and you can be able to
sort them uh by email so you can see
that okay so
and we have all that coming into apigee
now but now we need to expose
what we're doing to to the developers
we do that through a product and when we
create an api product
this is what actually gives us the
control
over how the api is
accessed by developers so what you see
here is i've created a product
called tracking details and i've made it
uh publicly available to any any
registered developer
so once once they've registered they can
have access to this
it's automatic approval i've set a quota
so any developer can actually only
access this once
or sorry five times each minute
i'm not setting any oauth scopes right
now
i set a path of slash which basically
means they have access to anything
any any paths uh on this particular
product
and then uh the interesting part here is
the istio services
now i bound this to this particular
service that i've already deployed
and that i opened up access to a second
ago and this is
the shipping service and this is the
full dns name
of the shipping service in kubernetes so
having set all that
we save that and we come back
and now we can register to use that api
in the portal
so i come to the portal and check out
the apis
oh there's there's my api it's the
tracking details and i've
i've already exposed uh this to the
portal
with um an open api
definition as you can see here
if you look at this open api definition
we have a get tracking
and you pass it a tracking number
and the body of a response
is going to have information such as the
carrier the status
tracking location things like that and
then you can see here we also have
the authentication requirements that it
requires either an api key
or a jot bearer token
so right now we don't have it protected
so we should be able to access it
with no additional work
and there we go so we get a
correct response now that's great
i can try the api but what i really want
to do
is create an app so that i can use the
api
as a developer because normally you're
not going to have the api
open to just anybody right
so what we're going to do
is protect the api with an api key
so now i've said that my api is no
longer public
it has to be a registered developer
because you have to have an api key to
access this and you'll notice
that we're saying it's any we're only
doing it for the shipping
destination uh and that's so that our
app can continue working
as normal the web app and this only
affects that shipping api
or the shipping service in fact so
let's go back to the portal again
now let's go here and
now we should see if we execute
yes we have a 403 permission denied
now we have to have an api key to access
it
and we can do that ourselves as well
but we have what we have to do is we
create an account
and sign in now i've already created an
account
so i'm going to log in with my account
and if we go here you can see that i
don't have
any apps well i have to create an app
so i'm going to call it my details
now once the app is created
you'll see that i have access right i
grant access
to this api and
add an api key for the app
now this should be able to be used
directly to try out that api
so let's go back to this api
so now we're going to authorize this
with the api key that we just created
and actually let me manually enter it
i'll show you the key
authorize and
we get a 200 okay and we're back in
business
excellent so api key is working for us
so now we need to try this with oauth
first of all we'll go ahead and
protect it with the oauth and you can
see here
we have an auth spec that tells it
we're using my issuer and where i get
the tokens
and where to retrieve my certs from
in this case we'll go ahead and apply
that
now when we apply that
that actually goes out to the proxy
so it's actually running on the envoy
and envoy retrieves that information and
can evaluate that
right there so let's go back to the
portal once again
now we'll try it with the same
authorization that we have before
and this time we get origin auth origin
authentication failed it's a different
error because that's coming from the
proxy
so now what we need to do is we need to
go back and we're we have to get
a token
so to get the token again go back into
our app
and we're gonna need the key and the
secret so let me grab the key
and i'm just going to go ahead and put
these in here
the secret put that in
here evaluate that
and then see if we can create
this token for us here's the token
that it's created and this is the actual
contents of what that token looks like
and you can see that we have all the
information
about the user in this so let's grab
this token and go ahead and put it in
the
in the bearer header and this
access and you can see now
we have access again
and i'll turn this back over to nandan
thank you what you've seen now
is the ability for us to extend the
steer mixer adapter
to apply api management rules in a
service mesh
so service management provides
the value of applying observability
operational agility and security to your
micro services
apigee extends service management and
seo to give you the ability to have a
portal to get api analytics
and then to apply api management rules
within your service mesh
like quotas apic identification or what
and all those
things that you typically associate with
service
with api management so i i hope you guys
like this talk i'm going to pause here
and see if there are any questions
once again uh thank you for attending
the webinar before we get into the q a
uh uh a couple of quick things uh and
you know apigee customers can sign up
for
uh their um for starting to use the
entire integration with service mesh
and then you have the other links over
there uh with regards to
what is uh available you have resources
which will be made available to you they
are available on the resource console
so those are call up you know you can go
ahead and download those
those um the stock leadership
documentation
with that i would like to quickly get on
to the the questions uh
that we have we have a lot of questions
someone you know tap it out to
two questions that i believe uh you know
london would you
would you want to take them up one is um
is mixed adapter the only way of
integrating mode with apigee
and istio currently yes within the
within the sphere itself that is
the point of extensibility that mixer is
where we extend it
um but of course our portal analytics
they all
read off of mixers so you get those uh
you get those benefits just through the
mixer extension
fantastic and i just had one final
question because i got a lot of good
things about this particular question is
with regard to the 13 minute key
rotation that was offered by
html is that something that's
configurable can you give us some more
information on that yeah it is
configurable uh 30 minutes i believe is
the default
but you can increase it okay fantastic
um unfortunately we are completely out
of time we will not be able to take any
more questions but before we go
uh thank you for your attendance we
really appreciate it thank you to all
the speakers uh
i wanted to call out special attention
to uh the next webinar that's coming up
on
september 26th uh it's about the craft
of api product management
it's going to be a great session that
will talk to you about frameworks
uh business models and kpis that you as
an api product manager manager need to
take note of
we're also going to have some
experiential learning experiential uh
learning where we have customers
enterprises just like you
who will share their story as to how
they've done some of these experts are
going to provide
as to how what kind of lessons they've
learned and what are the kind of advice
they can provide
so please feel free to register for the
webinar and we
you know look forward to learning uh you
know learning along with you
now with that said i think we're
completely out of time
thank you we really appreciate your time
today have a wonderful rest of your day
thank you
you